Hi it's me Michelle from Lab Muffin
Beauty Science. I'm a chemistry PhD
graduate who loves skincare science, and
today I'm going to be telling you about
how miceller water works. Micellar water
is a type of cleanser that's super
popular with makeup artists and beauty
addicts. The most famous micellar water
is probably Bioderma Sensibio H2O.
Apparently one bottle of this is sold
every five seconds worldwide. A quick
chemistry side note: it's H2O,
as in the letter O, not the number zero.
This is a pet peeve of mine as a chemist
because H2O is the molecular
formula for water. What this means is
that there are 2 hydrogen atoms
bonded to 1 oxygen atom. So we have two
Hs and one O. H20 would mean that
there are 20 hydrogens bonded together,
which just doesn't happen, except maybe
once in a star, somewhere. Anyway, back to
micellar water! Micellar waters are
cleansers that you pour into a cotton
pad, then wipe over your skin. You don't
need to rinse them after you use them, so
it's almost like makeup wipe liquid in a
bottle. How do they work? We're going to
have to talk about the physical
chemistry of surfactants to understand
what's going on. The key ingredients in
micellar water are a surfactant or
multiple surfactants, and water. Oil and
water usually repel each other and oil
won't dissolve in water or vice versa,
which is why you can't wash an oily dish
with plain water. This is because oil is
non-polar and water is polar.
It's like oil is velcro but water is a
magnet: they just don't work together.
This is a chemical principle that's
commonly known as "like dissolves like",
which means that oil and water don't
form sticky interactions with each other.
But if you add surfactants to the mix,
that's a different story.
Surfactants are nifty little molecules
that have two halves: a hydrophilic head
that's attracted to water and repels oil,
and a hydrophobic or lipophilic half
that's attracted to oils and grease and
repels water.
It's like you've sticky taped a magnet
to velcro. Now everything can stick
together in a big happy heap. In
chemistry this happy mixture is called
an emulsion. Because getting oil and
water to hang out together happily is
really handy, you'll find surfactants in
lots of products: soaps, shampoos,
dishwashing detergent, laundry powders,
moisturisers, foundations, mayonnaise, milk,
ice cream, and of course, micellar water.
For example with an oily dish, the
surfactants in the detergent can sink
into the oil. Then when you scrub the
dish, the surfactants break up the oil
into droplets. Since the surfactants hang
out at the surface between oil and water,
they sort of hide the oil from the water.
It's like it smuggles the oil into the
water so you can wash it away. It's the
same idea with mayonnaise. Oil and
vinegar usually don't mix, but if you
have lecithin from egg yolk as an
emulsifier or surfactant, it can smuggle
in droplets of oil into the vinegar, and
they stay together as a thick creamy
delicious goop. When you use micellar
water, you pour the product onto a cotton
pad. Cotton is made of cellulose which is
polar,
so the hydrophilic heads are going to
stick to the cotton like magnets and the
hydrophobic tails are going to stick out
on the surface of the pad like velcro.
And guess what? Make up and oils and
grease are non-polar, so they're like
velcro as well. So when you wipe the pad
over your skin, the tails will grab the
makeup and oils and grease so you end up with clean skin. You might be wondering
when I'm going to start talking about micelles. Micelles aren't actually that
important to how micellar water works.
When you add a surfactant to water,
like if you mix dishwashing detergent
with tap water, we have the hydrophilic
heads and the hydrophobic tails of the
surfactants and a bunch of water. Since
the hydrophobic tails don't like water
and the hydrophilic heads do, the
surfactant molecules are going to
arrange themselves or self-assemble so
the tails aren't touching the water.
They can do this in two ways. The tails
can stick out of the water into the air
at the surface, sort of like ostriches
burying their heads into the sand. Or
they can arrange themselves into little
balls with the heads at the surface and
the tails on the inside, sort of like
tiny pin cushions. These little balls are
called micelles. Any surfactant in water
will form micelles. The main difference
with micellar water is that it's
formulated so that the surfactants
aren't as damaging to your skin as a
standard rinse off cleanser.
Unfortunately since surfactants are sticky
they tend to stick to things in
your skin such as proteins, which changes
the structure of your skin. Since your
skin's main role is to act as a barrier
to keep water in and unwanted germs and
chemicals out, this means that you can
end up with a leaky barrier. Micellar
waters are made so that the surfactants
won't do this as much as a standard
rinse off cleanser. For example they tend
to contain gentler surfactants than a
regular cleanser. They're also sometimes
formulated with moisturizing ingredients
like fatty acid esters to keep the skin
barrier intact. But for some people who
have sensitive skin, even micellar water
might be too much. So if you find that
your skin is dry or itchy or tight after
you use micellar water, you can try
wiping it off or rinsing it off with a
wet towel or just water. So that's how micellar water works! I hope you found this
video useful. If you liked it please
subscribe to my channel, check out my
blog, follow me on Instagram, send me cake, send me science memes and I'll see you
next time for more beauty science :)